well we're getting back to our
remarkable women's series this morning
the pandemic sidelined hundreds of
thousands of nevadans from their jobs
and their incomes creating a tsunami of
unpaid rents and mortgages and fear for
homeowners but thanks to our next
remarkable woman kristen schuler heinz
with her tireless heart for helping
others hundreds of those people were
spared being evicted
[Music]
i don't want to see anybody lose their
home this happens to people who've never
missed a mortgage payment people who've
bought a house with the intention of
living in it until the day they die or
leaving it at their children kristen
schuler heintz knew she had to do
something to help residents hang on to
their homes while also helping her
company survive one of the things that
we always try to focus on is
what can we do to help people understand
what their rights are what their
obligations are what kind of help is out
there kristin is an attorney with
mccarthy and holthus a law firm that
represents banks and mortgage lenders
clients who loan people money to buy a
home and can legally take back that
property if you stop making payments we
don't blame you
for not being able to pay your mortgage
we don't think you're a bad person we
understand this happens what can we do
to help you help yourself and when covid
began taking its financial toll on the
community kristin pivoted to help her
clients customers navigate the arduous
paperwork journey to avoid eviction
many without a computer or internet
service and if you're trying to register
for eviction assistance
through
um your phone
and trying to find the documents to
upload get hold of people
you know they they can't do it
remarkably kristin has helped more than
500 homeowners stay securely put during
a very uncertain time but her heart for
helping goes far beyond her job she also
helped friends and others especially
seniors get those coveted first coveted
vaccines when appointments seemed
impossible if you weren't sitting at the
computer all day long checking for
appointments and trying to get in you
couldn't get one
so i
i was in front of my computer all day
long anyway so why not have one screen
directed to getting people vaccine
appointments and the other screen
directed to him doing my work and that's
just what she did even driving some to
get their shots like 73 year old ellen
maccabee and waiting in line with her
for hours kristen and her husband also
give their time to many different
non-profits from holiday toy and food
drives to alzheimer's and the aids
foundation as an entertainer back in the
1980s kristin saw many performers some
friends lose their fight with aids i
hope before i die that we say aids is
cured that would be the best thing ever
to take with me is that
whatever little bit i've done
has stopped people from dying
from aids and her family is made up of
adopted special needs four-legged kids
from local pet rescues we adopted a dog
from the humane society because it's set
on it foreclosure and it's like i don't
care what dog we're here for we're
taking that one too kristin also mentors
young nevada attorneys and says she
hopes that by setting an example for
them and for all young people that
helping others just a little every day
can have a big impact over time i get up
and i do my job and i try to do it in
the nicest way possible
so that people's lives are made maybe a
little bit better and i think that's
that's all you can that's all you can do
is try to make people's lives just a
little bit better every day a heart for
giving and a never-ending spirit for
helping others that's why kristen
schuler heinz is an eight news now
remarkable woman
[Music]
well congratulations to kristen
and i think she's very deserving you
wonder how people find so much time when
they're so busy themselves but yet
people who have such a heart they make
time and to save her client
i mean she works for mortgage lenders
and banks yeah but yet
she went to the homeowners and said let
me help you get through this we're gonna
we're gonna help you stay in your house
right now because the pandemic was
taking its toll on all of us and she
doesn't she didn't want anybody to be
evicted from their home so wow did some
uh miraculous things
couple years paperwork to buy a house
and do your house stuff is hard enough
as it is let alone with the pandemic and
the issue of foreclosures and the you
know the benefit money that was coming
in trying to navigate that entire
rigmarole uh props to her but what uh
she does great work in the community
love that and so many people didn't have
internet they were trying to do this
stuff on their phone she said no let me
help you wow she's incredible she's
remarkable yes it's remarkable